[Music]
[Music]
how's bobby
i miss you both so much
i'm heading out on another secret
mission
i want to come see you but
i need to keep fighting
everything i do
is to protect you
back come here
keep your eyes open
the game is called get in the car as
fast as humanly possible you let him
beat you
um i would love to know kind of just
what inspired the story as you co-wrote
it as well what inspired it you know
what were you thinking about
um so the original script was written
something like 10 years ago which is
kind of strange because it's even more
prescient and you know has even more
resonances now of course with this like
invisible threat affecting the
population um and the thing that i mean
i read it a couple of years ago the
thing that i identified with was this
family dynamic it was this relationship
between a father and his two kids and
how it was it was just like a really
tender study of this coming of age
moment that the three of them
you know went through um and it felt
like there was something really truthful
and universal in that and i had all
these genre elements and it was told on
this really big epic canvas but i just
found a very poignant story and it's so
rare that you find
yeah you find a script that's very
personal and very delicate and tender
but it's also really ambitious in terms
of scale but it was really like an
emotional connection that drew me to the
material first
did anybody notice that my character's
name was pia in this movie
uh michael was kind enough to let us
rename our characters and make them a
little bit more accurate to who we would
probably be
and i named my character after this
actual woman right there yeah
the community is very close and very
strong and supportive and
i just love that the first thing we see
is like you and your bad self you like
walk up
like it's like just emblazoned on the
heart it's great i like it okay continue
with the very everybody told me that 20
my 2021 bingo card would involve rizz
ahmed with my name tattooed on his chest
[Laughter]
i have to say that was an insane moment
for me uh the name pia is not in
hollywood movies and i love movies and
i've never seen that so
uh when janina told me i honestly i
still don't know how to feel about this
but i am so
i feel good it's okay i'm also really
happy that she didn't die from the
parent side
so that that's that but yeah this
when we talk about representation
as a south asian woman i have to say oh
yeah representation is really important
this woman literally like
put my name in a movie and so that is
you know can't get over that which is
incredible but anyways um what i did
when i was oh no i'm sorry no no no no
no no no
i know i know i do okay you're right
we'll figure this out i'm sure there's
some
there'll be some pavement involved in
something
probably with donuts but
so janine i'd love to ask you when you
came on how did you and riz talk about
this family and how you wanted to
portray them
great question um well we we first
talked about how we
met and and really built a that kind of
story and then at some point we're like
do you want to name our babies
um and and we
made sure that those names reflected the
names that we would probably name our
children and we didn't have to actually
change them too much i think they were
originally jack and bobby and then we
just changed them to jay yeah
and then we and then like we changed it
to j and bobby yeah yeah yeah did you
get to pick which one you would be i did
yeah okay
would you rather vintage
name i think so i like your name yeah
yeah i actually asked alexa here like so
what is bobby
figured out that bobby means policemen
bobby
bobby is a policeman
yeah really great point
did that influence how you played the
character
i mean i don't know i didn't feel like
you were very policeman but in a good
way i don't think you're like a
policeman so that's good
um updated spencer hello hello hello um
i so i really really loved how hattie
here is
you know the character who just
maintains belief and malik all
throughout and even as the audience
learns more about him your character is
adamant that you wanted to believe in
him tell me a little bit about how you
connected to her and if there was any
research involved in the kind of work
that she was doing and why you felt like
your character felt that connection
there's always research um in in every
character that you play because
someone else's life and lived experience
is usually different from your own and
michael had already given me a lot of
stuff that he wanted me to
to to
take into account as i you know broke
the character down but
for me after i did all of that and and
just tried to map out uh the character's
art i just
i saw her as a you know a strong woman
who had likely been dismissed in her
workplace a lot
who
was working with criminals who would
often be dismissed in the world because
they had had that label
and
she you know administered tough love and
if you responded to that the way i'm
sure she felt that malik responded to
that
um then she you know
uh
reciprocated and kind and and wanted to
to
have that you to
you know
reinvent yourself and and and present a
better face to society and that's what
she wanted for malik but when he made
that that turn to kidnap his boys she
knew she had to intervene to get him to
to come home and to make sure he wasn't
shot on site you know yeah
um
i'd love to ask you a little bit about
you know what drew you immediately to
malik and
um
you know his story is such a fascinating
one he goes through a very deep mental
journey in this
uh which parts of that did you feel like
you were compelled by and and you know
then what kind of research did you have
to go off in and do about that as well
i mean initially what attracted me to
this film was michael pierce
you know i think he's i believe he's one
of our uh great emerging filmmakers and
i think he's going to be here for a very
long time
i agree
i like that anyone who's
[Applause]
he's
you know it's very unusual to see a
script or a story that tries to bridge
all these different tones you know
you've got that action that sci-fi kind
of element but it's a family story it's
heartwarming you've got these guys
cracking jokes in it you've got the
whole gamut of emotions you know you've
got the whole thing in there
and um
and also i found it scary the idea of
playing dad i was like these guys are
going to laugh at me because i don't
know how to be a dad they're going to be
like that's not how you do it
idiot so uh did they
well yeah
that's also probably what the character
malik is thinking like i'm an imposter i
don't know how to be a dad i haven't
seen my kids for years so when i
realized there's that overlap between
what you're thinking what the
character's thinking
even if it's a scary thought that's the
kind of weigh-in
is it working no these don't these are
yeah
he's working there we go
there we go
so yeah so that's what attracted me to
the role uh
filmmaker badass kids
i mean really that's the perfect formula
i think right so
um michael you made this very
interesting decision
you didn't ask your question
sorry there was a reason where we're
going to go into the perspectives but
you were right i'm going to come okay
he's ready he's ready
all right
are you ready okay no the mic isn't
working it's working
your character actually you know you
kind of go along for the ride initially
but then you and your brother you start
to figure things out and i just want to
kind of you know how did you
and uh river
talk about your relationship as brothers
and how did you two bond as brothers
i mean
talking to your mind
we did we it was actually we knew each
other before we met at michael's place
so we so we actually bonded during a
chemistry feed
so we actually uh learned that we both
love beyblades which are these like
spinning tops
that
might that we both love i mean it's a
whole different universe
yeah we also actually got michael and
rizzo to play
were you able to play with them on set
and um
not really not really because we didn't
like time sorry
focus
we did love like
we did love making up songs we we we
like we bonded like me and we were
bonded because we would start to make up
songs together and
pop in
rich just got involved in that challenge
you started a band really
well okay three musketeers yeah
look out for the album twenty twenty
twenty twenty twenty three okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i feel like you sort of kept the uh
you kept the perspective see i feel like
i can't even ask serious questions
[Laughter]
you kept the audience on on malik's
perspective for a good chunk of this
before we really realized what was going
on uh what was your you know what was
behind that decision to follow that and
really get you know show how he was
seeing things
um it came from just wanting to be very
compassionate towards a character
because in some ways you could make
you know this film from one perspective
is about a mentally unwell man that
kidnaps his children for the weekend and
then he's hunted by law enforcement
right and if i told a really
um
objective study of that it could have
just distanced you from the character
and all the research that i did around
people that were experiencing psychosis
in its different forms was that of
course they don't see themselves as
mentally unwell they're they're in some
kind of magical fantasy world you know
and sometimes it's nightmarish and
sometimes it's exhilarating and i
thought well genre is a tool to get
inside that character's head and it will
get the audience inside that character's
head and then when you start to follow
octavia's character and you realize
something's not that's not the whole
truth
you still have the knowledge of that
first half an hour of you know you
comprehend why he's doing it and what's
motivating him and i just hadn't seen
that uh done before in film usually you
you're very aware when some someone's
mentally unwell because and it seems
very
uh you know they they seem
to you know behaviorally to like uh
really show a lot of exhibit a lot of
signs that they're unwell i just thought
there's a there's a way to be more
empathetic to what they're experiencing
so that's what it came from
i think that was an incredible choice
actually because um yeah we did feel
like we were really seeing
the things he was experiencing and so
you were on that journey you did believe
he was saving his voice and that felt
very compelling um
risk for you playing a
a marine combat veteran as well um you
know what was that experience like you
know getting into that that mindset and
what did you sort of learn about that
experience that you wanted to bring to
your character
well man there's a lot i could say about
this it was really fascinating and sure
i think one of the things i love most
about this job is the people you get to
meet and where you get to get a glimpse
into different people's lives and
experiences so i always love to
interview people
meet up with
in this case lots of us special forces
veterans or active servicemen and record
them and record these really long
conversations
and i listen to that a lot so i can
imagine myself into their stories or
sometimes it forms the basis of an
accent and what was interesting for me
was you know
i i never wouldn't necessarily think of
myself as playing a role like this for
many different reasons but
i guess something i realize there's a
lot of people out there fighting these
walls they're not fighting really for a
flag or an ideology they're fighting for
the person so they're left into their
right
they're fighting for a sense of family
yeah and um and what i also found is you
know not to generalize many people i
spoke to
you know went through a lot of damage
and were carrying a lot of scars from
their early life and so that sense of
belonging in family was something they
found in the armed forces but of course
the irony is
in their service they come back with
even more damage and scars and so that
really kind of expanded my empathy and
challenged some of my assumptions about
what character i believe or someone in
that profession would really be
motivated by
make sense i did hear what beyblade
should i be investing in right now
i'm kidding
um
what was your favorite scene to film in
this film
in this building this film
i mean
i don't really have one i have multiple
okay okay what was the one that was like
maybe the most challenging for you
because you did do a lot of running
around you did a lot of you know
physical stuff here so was there one
that was particularly difficult
i think the action man scene like when i
dropped my toy
because
i would never do that to my real
so we toys not getting the feeling
so
my kid
got like all the babies i had yeah that
he knew i had beforehand
and then he put them in like his
backpack
and then off camera wrist just started
chucking them out of the window
you sacrificed the beyblades
they were doubles
we bought them
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
right
and
it was it was like really challenging
because i had knee pads right our
stuntman and
like we had to put knee pads okay
i mean listen you made it really
convincing truly you did an incredible
job in that scene
[Applause]
[Music]
my
he just looked at me like you're dead
[Laughter]
janina i would love to ask you a little
bit about you know
this playing a family like this in a
movie like this you know we talk a lot
about representation but what did it
mean to just you know play an
all-american family that just happens to
look like this and and play out this
this way it's weird because i'm from
illinois i'm from joliet illinois man
like i grew up in
the outside of chicago
hella regular you know what i mean yeah
and so
you move to
hollywood and people start sort of
building an idea of who you're supposed
to be and how you're supposed to be
portrayed so
we're just so early in the conversation
and the history of representation
that it's strange to be in 2021 and have
this be progressive how is this
progressive it's very normal
but you know listen the thing is that
we're doing these things now so these
kids have no problem later and they're
like when they watch this movie in 20
years they're going to be like why did
anybody care that this was right
you know and this is something i give
you credit for because you've constantly
been taking roles where you're not you
know you're not letting yourself get
boxed in like that yeah you're not gonna
you can't exoticize me come on i'm just
like i like being exotic
do it
lady take them
do it no
i'm kidding but i'm not
oh david you've been in like so many
different kinds of movies but you know
and so many of them are dealing with
social commentary in so many different
ways this one has this very interesting
mix of like a psychological thriller and
the sci-fi component as well but what do
you think it sort of lends to
the social commentary of like 2021
because it can't distance itself from
the year it's coming out in well it's
it's definitely indicative of the time
that we're living right now how many of
us weren't i mean if you're going to be
honest you've all been as paranoid as
malik with the hand washing and the i
have a tiny little can of lysol in my
purse right now you know
just to so
what i loved about this movie is that it
did all of this genre bending
and it made me realize that um
even though malik was an unreliable
narrator in my mind he was the most
reliable because we always put ourselves
first and we never take into account
another person's journey and mental
health is real
mental health issues are real they are
painful for the people who are
experiencing them so what michael was
able to do
was
put us in malik's body and we experience
it experience it
at you know real time and while it may
not have been real for us
it was truly real for him because he
wouldn't have done all of that
to protect his boys and that made me
realize that i have to to work harder at
being more empathetic and more
compassionate and understanding that
everybody's walking in life is
completely different and we have to take
that into account
because that is kind of what the core of
the film is um
i think for you you know what do you
feel
because your character is the one you're
the you're the journey we go on in this
film so you know what do you feel your
character is able to represent in
in the year we live in and i think
octavia may have answered some of this
but yeah how do you feel like that
character and his journey resonates with
the world we live in right now
yeah i guess um
you know it's someone who's trying to
save
their family at all costs in an
uncertain world
um
and i think that this it's so resonant
because you know we're on set filming
this kind of
you know
sci-fi-esque
thriller
and we didn't really have to take much
of an imaginative leap because look
behind the camera and everyone's wearing
a biohazard suit
sky is dark orange from the california
forest fire
and it's the middle of the elections
that were taking place in 2020 and
there's civil unrest everywhere we need
security on set because it's you know
kind of things kicking off everywhere i
remember that so it's a oh come to you
so i guess it's just this idea that like
this isn't science fiction this is not
sci-fi this is now fight this is more
grounded and urgent and more reflective
of the times we live in than
many of the films are out there right
now and i think it's really uh admirable
and ambitious
uh the way that michael's managed to do
that and give us a social commentary
without giving us a film that feels
earnest or worthy or preachy that takes
us on the thrill ride that we love to
see when we go to the movies
um and gives us all those different
emotions so i hope this film more than
anything represents what movies and
going to the movies can be it's not
based on ip
it's an original script
it's super diverse and it kicks ass so
i'm really proud of that
[Applause]
i think we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to wrap this with you
what are your thoughts on this film and
what would you like audiences to take
from it
did i just lump in with it i want
the audience to
to take that yeah it will be action
it will be
gonna be sci-fi
but
what it's really about
i hope the audience will take this
but what it's really about is protecting
your family and loving them no matter
who they are
[Applause]
thank you all so much for being here uh
i really appreciate it i i also love
that all of you are out here on a friday
night watching this movie on a big
screen because it is important to see
these things on a big screen if and when
you can and so
and if not then it is also on amazon
prime so thank you all for being here so
much
[Applause]
[Music]